[Music]
yemeni soldiers pushed back
houthi advances on two fronts north of
the city of madrid
battles like this one have intensified
since the start of the month
the houthis have been wrestling to take
the last saudi-backed government
stronghold
in northern yemen for over a year the
violence has resulted in dozens of
deaths
and in a tweet u.n humanitarian chief
mark lukakus warned
the assault would put two million lives
at risk
and could cause unimaginable
humanitarian consequences
the us is calling for the houthis to
halt their advance
you know our hope is that a combined
effort bringing in
certain partners at certain times packed
with a strong
very strong american position will um
will essentially shake up the
architecture and put us in a much better
place
to push for that negotiated settlement
which i think we all agree is the only
way forward
on tuesday the u.s lifted the previous
administration's designation
of the houthis as a terrorist
organization
and in a further departure president
biden ended u.s support
for the saudi-led military offensive in
yemen
for their part houthis accused the
yemeni government
of being the aggressors i don't see tim
lenderking at this point
approaching the houthis directly but
he probably should i understand the
significance of marib for them
they may gain a few kilometers they may
even gain the city
but they lose the peace and eventually
they will only prolong the war if they
persist
some analysts say houthis are using the
fight in marrab
as leverage in any future negotiations
but advancements have been slow with
saudi arabia intensifying airstrikes
rights groups say 650 families have been
displaced
and many more could follow but the u.s
administration
hopes it can prevent further bloodshed
and help bring the six-year war
to an end laura about a manly al jazeera